i wanted to ask you because you just had
the big fun
gender announcement um with your
girlfriend
jenna and you guys met right before the
pandemic
and you just announced that you're
having a baby boy congratulations
thank you very much thank you a mini
derulo
yeah i could not be more excited it's a
boy
um i i you know i i think um
everything you know happens in like in
the right time like i
i was just starting to like really like
get
a baby fever you know i guess you know
with age and you meet someone that you
really really connect with um and yeah
you know it happened at just the right
time for me that's interesting i haven't
heard a man talk about baby fever we're
usually the ones saddled with the like
tick tock and you know men sometimes are
like oh
god don't you know the pressure and
we're like i know i gotta
keep the human race going i know um
but it's it's interesting to hear a man
say that and really
wonderful how is um
your beautiful lady jenna feeling um
so she's actually good uh it hasn't been
a
tough pregnancy at all um so yeah she
she's she's been really good she the
worst thing that happens i guess is
um he just kicks a lot you know whenever
he hears music
he just starts dancing it's like i want
to do a tick tock on it because i just
picture him
in there just getting it well
with the world that you create jason i
feel like you can create a womb and a
mini derulo
for sure if you wanted to all right next
on the list
[Laughter]
you know i've always gravitated towards
people in my life
that i really looked up to and i know
that you and will smith have this
amazing
sort of like friendship and
will you talk about that a little bit
yeah for sure
um i i totally agree with you i mean
being able to
uh befriend someone that you um
look up to uh i think there's nothing
like it
uh when will smith says something you
want to make sure that you're listening
because you got to put that in your back
pocket
you know he gives you life advice
without even knowing he giving you life
advice so i'd be like okay cool
i'm gonna take that i'm gonna put that
right yeah cool
uh but it's it's incredible you know i
grew up watching him um
and what he's been able to accomplish in
in different
uh uh genres right i mean it's
it's just really uh unbelievable so to
be able to
um you know have a friend that i can
learn from all the time you know
there's just nothing like that it's so
true and it really makes me think about
your manager story is it true that you
met him
at a basketball game when you were like
12 years old
yeah yeah on a basketball court he had
these little he had
short shorts on and some high socks and
um
yeah i remember uh we needed one more
player and i was like ah
cool i'll take the old guy come on and
then he ended up being this
crazy basketball player um and uh
he started to mentor me uh as as a
basketball player because that previous
year
i didn't make my basketball team um and
i asked if he would help me with my
basketball
and he was just in law school at the
time and um he would just help me with
my basketball and that's what it was at
that time
and then how did your relationship
transpire because you guys are still
together right
yeah for sure so um basically
you know he would just whoop on me all
the time in basketball
uh and then one day i was like you know
what basketball is not even my day
i'm a singer and he's like oh come on
get out of here
um and uh uh he was like i could sing
and then i sang something he was like
wow
you really have something and then um at
that point he tried to act like he had
like all these connections um and he had
a little something some
but we flew out to new york to meet all
of his connections
um door after door was shut in our face
but um
we stuck to it and we learned together
um
and we uh continue to
to build you know what we have today
which is you know
13 businesses and um a lustrous empire
i'm glad that he recognized your talent
uh with your voice and helped you know
stick with you and help you pave the way
for yourself
and i'm really excited to talk about
your latest single
lifestyles with another phenomenal voice
adam levine um i think the combination
of the two of you just sounds about as
good as it gets
but how did it come about you know what
um it was a pandemic collaboration
um one that happened remotely um i had
fit i finished the
the song and i loved the song
lifestyle and i sent it to my friend who
was um
also a writer on the song jay cash and
he
frequently works with adam um as well
and i was like yo send us to adam and
find out what he thinks about it
uh adam loved it and progressed his
history i think that's again i'm just
gonna say it one last time what i really
recognize
in you is these ideas are self-generated
and i really
really respect that about you and i
thank you for putting all the good stuff
that you do out into the world jason
derulo
[Applause]
i really mean it keep building and we
will all come
check out jason derulo's single
lifestyle featuring
adam levine and i can't wait to check in
with you jenna and minnie derulo and see
how you're all doing
okay well i will talk to you soon very
soon thank you so much
i look so forward